all right good morning welcome to Jael
car uh let see seeing
alternates I'm here
[Music]
Jackie all right Senator gray you can
sit sit in for Senator
Lang representative grassie you can sit
in for representative Schmid and
representative hacken Phillips you can
sit in for representative
L since we're here we do have a
quorum the minutes of the previous
meeting do we have a
motion second
oops multiply seconded but moved by
represent by Senator Ward any represent
director Merl I think you made two
appointments for Senator Lang no no no
um represent the other one was for
representative Leon I
apologize sorry about
mumbling any discussion on the
minutes those in favor I
opposed
okay is there anything that someone
wants to remove from the consent
agenda
oops all right representative
representative grassy since
representative Schmidt has shown up you
are in for Senator
inis all
right again is there anything to be
removed from the ENT
agenda seeing nothing is there a
motion s all right moved by Senator Ward
seconded by Senator gray any
discussion okay those in favor I
opposed all right on the not the regular
agenda we have a number of items that
should be
postponed
do does someone wish to make a motion to
postpone items d f g and
K the chairwoman we need to add item a
as well and a all right we will postpone
that one as
well and we will need waivers
for at least the first
one and
and I believe the board of dental
examiners as
well so
representative representative Schmidt
has moved that we postpone those items
to our March meeting I'm sorry could
could someone please um repeat the item
numbers I just got the A and then a
alpha the natural scientists D
Professional
Engineers f and g which are the
department of energy
and K which is the board of dental
examiners thank
you I'll second the
postponement okay I
believe any
discussion all right seeing none those
in favor I I
opposed then that leaves us to deal with
the department of safety items B and
then C okay um so the first item which
is 202 23
163 um has to do with non-resident
pistol revolver license I did have a
couple substantial comments on this
however I did also have a conversation
with the Department yesterday that
clarified some of these comments um so
for example the first one on page one of
the rule text I had a legislative
unclear comment because the agency had
deleted the paragraph applicability from
the final proposal text text and it was
unclear why they did that especially
because it talked about the exemption in
RSA
6D um for non-residents in reciprocal
states but when I talked to the
department they clarified that this was
done due to some public comment that
they had received and additionally when
you look at the purpose section it makes
uh it clear that this application is is
really optional so the purpose itself
for non-residents who wish to obtain not
that they have to obtain So based on
that language and the fact that this was
based on some public comment they
received um I would say that addresses
that
comment the next comment was on page two
it's an unclear comment um this has to
do with the written notice the
Department is supposed to provide a
lensey when they suspend or revoke a
rule uh it's required by Statute that
they provide that uh under our RSA 159
6B but in the sections for revocation
and suspension they did not mention
anything about notice uh when I talked
to the department they said that the
notice is provided as is required by 541
a30 and my recommendation is that they
include that somewhere in the rules so
that someone who's looking at them knows
to look to RSA 541 a30 to know that they
will receive notice
um and that they will receive notice if
it's an emergency
revocation um that they're entitled to a
hearing within 10
days the next comment I had is also on
page two it's an unclear legislative
intent
comment um the statute specifically
allows a license to remain in effect
until it expires when a license C uh
ceases to be a resident of the community
in which the license C was
the license was issued after notifying
the issuing authority of the lenes new
place of
residence um however the rule text says
that once a lensey moves to New
Hampshire their license is automatically
revoked so the legislative intent for
that statute is a bit unclear when it
comes to non-residents whether that is
an automatic revocation or if the
license would continue as long as that
non-resident gave notice to the
Department
and the final comment I had is at the
bottom of page two with regard to the um
venue for non-residents should they wish
to appeal a revocation or suspension of
their license the rule text says
specifically that the venue would be the
conquered District Court which does have
personal jurisdiction over the
department um however the statute
specific specifically says that a person
must petition the district or M
Municipal Court in the jurisdiction in
which such person resides so there is
just a little bit of some unclear
legislative intent there says person not
resident and you know as I'm sure uh
representative Lynn is aware personal
jurisdiction over state agencies um you
can't really sue them outside of their
own state court so just might need a
little clarification on that point
but that's all the comments I had on
this
proposal okay any questions from the
oh don't see any questions from the
committee so if you'd care to
respond do turn it
on sorry thanks my name's Mar moani I'm
representing the department of safety I
have Lieutenant U Mary Bia from the
division of State Police with me as well
um I I did speak speak with
uh attorney Ricard yesterday um and she
she pretty much represented um our
position here we do conform with RSA 541
a30 for any um suspensions or and
notices of revocation we think the
statute is very clear of what is
required of the agency before taking any
action um with regards to to safc
24.02 um with regards to when a li a
non-resident pistol permit that we've
issued pursuant to statute and rules
once the um leny becomes a resident we
believe that they're required by Statute
to go to the chief of police and get
their resident concealed carry from that
um that town um and
so and then of course the last one we
just don't agree that we can submit to
to jurisdiction outside the state of New
Hampshire okay
questions
Senator we have some public comment
first if you don't
mind Miss
Dean and if you would uh Focus your
comments on the rule in front of us
please
sorry
certainly that's exactly what I intended
to
do what I see here at least the rule I
have that's
published that was published um by jel
car on the website has a several
problems um first of
all if you look under safe
.01 um the lensey is under indictment
for a crime punishable by imprisonment
for a term exceeding one
year that's something new that's not
what federal law actually provides they
provide you can't purchase anymore but
it doesn't say anymore about possession
or anything else so what they're doing
is adding to the law
now okay that's a that's a very clear
statement M miglani do you wish to
address that I was going to continue
ma'am sorry just because I think that
here's what someone is going to say next
so I want to address all of those things
uh as a please wait till she actually
says it if that's okay no well I will
wait but I think it would be helpful to
the committee to hear the rest of it
but m m Leana do you have any response
to
that okay then then please continue yes
as a practical matter I understand that
some judges
will make a condition of bail that you
not be allowed to have firearms in many
instances but not all instances I've had
clients indicted for felonies including
felony of allegedly pointing a firearm
at someone where the police promptly
returned their firearms and the court
did not make as a condition of their
bail that they couldn't have firearms
and and the low normal things which is
Edge weapons and they go down the
laundry list that's something that would
depend in some states depending on
statutory law or in this case depending
on the trial judge and to a certain
degree the prosecutor so what you're
doing is making non-residents have
additional um conditions that a resident
doesn't have and I argue that 1596 is
very clear and that's that if you
lawfully can own guns you get a license
and I don't see anything in the
statutory law that allows them to revoke
based on this new condition that's
number one and then may a continue with
the rest the let ma'am or
chairman
um
21301 I don't believe the laundry list
is statutorily correct because again I
go back to the fact that we are not to
be treat exuse me
21301 I apologize 21301 that says that
there are two items a license shall be
denied if the applicant is prohibited by
federal law or the applicant is
prohibited by New Hampshire statute it
it says period becomes a resident of New
Hampshire is what the here's what I read
C saying oh you're you're actually on
2104 oh I'm sorry
02 um
21402 conditions for revocation yes
thank you that that was the one that we
questioned earlier go please please
continue yes um and so
the other Pro let me look at the form
because I wanted to make a specific
comment on the form
um excuse
me
the other issue is the suspension or
revocation
hearings I
believe that a lensey is not required to
provide a reason for contesting the
suspension or revocation if someone ask
for a hearing or contesting it under 15
1596 normally they simply asked for a
hearing and I apologize I didn't bring
my water up they don't have to provide
what's found in safc
21051 form of request B4 it says the
reason for contesting the suspension or
revocation that's not required if one's
a resident and I don't believe that the
law gives them the authority to add
conditions like this to a
non-resident I think the law is very
clear um the other thing and I think
this is a really big issue safc
21052 time of request all requests for
hearings shall be addressed to the
commissioner and shall be postmarked or
otherwise received in the office of the
commissioner within 7 days from the date
of the suspension or
revocation I in conquered and there's
things from one town over that I
sometimes get depending on my mail
service up to seven days and so you're
talking about a non-resonant where we're
going to be mailing something to another
state who California Oregon who who
knows where even if we're mailing it to
Massachusetts they may not
um receive it in time to even file that
request and I think you're going to get
people just giving up saying well gee I
can't file it was in 7 days because this
21052 time request says shall be
addressed to the commissioner and shall
be postmarked or otherwise received in
the office of the commissioner with
postmark being the easiest one to make
within seven days from the DAT of
suspension or
revocation if
you revoke something today even in good
faith I've talked more than once at the
people of the Department of Safety and
DMV they put it in a giant mailbox in
excuse me to just grab my water so I
don't excuse me thank
you even if the employee there didn't
put it in the mail carrier service to go
out it may be a day or so before it
leaves a state agency and I don't think
that it's
possible in many cases that it may be
received by the person within seven days
and furthermore if a person's on
vacation or away on a business trip they
may not receive that that seven days is
patently
unreasonable period of time and I think
it's it's a DEA facto for most people
they're not going to make the
timeline the safc
21053 procedure for hearings
um that is going to be subject to
changes over time so I think that may or
may not be a problem um
the other thing is there's no further
rules about how long the hearing can
last or anything like that and I think
it's subject to
whim what it essentially is saying too
is that if someone's license is revoked
if they don't essentially or suspension
or revocation if they essentially don't
meet the first time
period they may or may not be arguably
able to appeal from the decision
pursuant to RSA
1596c and so the other issue
is
replication the next
problem
sorry the next problem that we have
still is that nonresidents are I believe
still being treated differently than
residents are going to be treated and I
think under the statute that's not
allowed I think Department of Safety is
reaching above and beyond the authority
they have under the
law and
so
um thank you very much and I'm happy to
answer practical
questions are questions representative
yes sir I just want to make sure I'm
understanding does the
um are there is there another section of
the regulations it says when the
department sends out a notice saying we
we
are suspending or revoking your license
this is the reason we're doing it do
they have to tell the person the reason
absolutely all right so if they have to
tell the person the reason what's the
problem with with asking somebody who
who wants to contest that to say this is
the reason I contest it I'll tell you
what the reason is um when a person says
not guilty they don't have to say
what ciled it's not a criminal
proceeding this is a civil or yes sir I
understand that um I think the problem
is still that there's no reason you are
not required to under state law if
you're a resident and what you're doing
is adding more conditions to
non-resident and I don't believe that
the law
1596 gives them the authority to treat
non-residents differently if I were a
resident and my license was suspended or
revoked I file for a hearing
um in conquer District Court I don't
have to provide that right right but
isn't the isn't the I'm I'm just trying
to be practical here is so let's so
let's suppose we say you don't have to
provide the reason so now you get to
court and the the the department says um
or you get to the hearing the department
says we want to suspend we're going to
suspend you for this reason and you come
in with some novel
response um isn't it very likely the was
going to say okay we're going to
continue the hearing we're going to
continue the hearing because we the the
state didn't have notice that you were
going to raise this novel response
whereas if you had if you had told them
in the beginning they would then then
they couldn't make that argument so it
just seems like it's you're you're just
delaying things unreasonably I don't
understand that I don't believe you're
delaying things unreasonably I think
what likely is even more important to me
is that I don't want the person to
face
um what may may or may not later be a
fuic victory because the person an
average person is not going to be able
to give a lawyer response about
why the Department's reason
for revoking their license is incorrect
I think what's very common that a lot of
people when they get notices like this
will file a response and they'll later
on second thought or talking to friends
or family will say gee I need to get a
lawyer for this and the question is and
I I think the answer a lot of times is
unfortunate is will the lawyer be able
to amend that reason because the
department out of hand says well this
reason's not the right reason or it's
not
adequate and the question is the lawyer
says well I know the person wrote that
reason but that's not the actual reason
that this is incorrect the person was a
lay person and they didn't
understand and I think that's an issue
that you're talking about right back
going around that Circle um is that
lawyer later going to be allowed to
amend
that all right or or further
sir is the department going to say we
have no reason for hearing because his
reason doesn't cut mustard and this is
not a reason to contest the
suspension they're going to say it's an
issue of law we decided his reason wrong
is there a provision that allows them to
do
that I don't think that here's what I've
heard them say more than one there's not
a provision that says I can't I've had
more than one chief of police smirk when
we had the fingerprint and photograph
issue until we added that to the statute
and they would smirk and say the law
doesn't say I
can't okay thank you um
direct just really quickly with regard
to the timeline for regard for notice of
suspension RSA 159 6B one specifically
says that a lensey Whose license has
been suspended or revoked shall be
permitted a hearing on such suspension
or revocation if a hearing is requested
by the Len to the issuing authority
within 7 Days of the suspension or
revocation so it seems like the rule
text is quoting directly from the
statute but it doesn't say it doesn't
say where it goes specifically here
postm marker received within seven days
of and I think that's the issue that
we're looking at here is when you're out
of state it's different if you mail
things from con I'm sorry if you mail
things from conquered or another area in
the state even then it's more likely to
be received you're
talking a person can in theory can have
a license a non-resident license for any
one of the other 49 states which include
Alaska Hawaii and
California
and there's some places you can't even
get overnight service to even if you go
to FedEx or or whatever um with letters
the Postal Service in conquered New
Hampshire no longer has certain
overnight Services well I see your point
but if the statute says that it the the
request for a hearing must be done
within seven days I don't think the rule
should contradict
that yeah and this might need to be
Senator gray the question for the
witness are over I think lot
turn your mic on that need to happen um
and I'm prepared to make motion that
this rule be accepted uh with the
provision that the department seek res
uh resolution uh through the legislature
for the conflicts that were noted and
that will give the witness time to um
pursue uh the things that she is trying
to do uh when that uh uh Amendment comes
up full legislature I'll second I'll
second that
motion okay are there any other
questions yeah I I do have a concern
about this I I'm
the I guess I'm I I share the the
staff's uh concern about the legislative
intent of of um sort of
automatically providing for suspension
of a non-resident license if the person
becomes a licensed becomes a New
Hampshire resident I'm not I mean it
seems to me that if the legis if the if
the statute
allows a license a a an instate liy to
keep their license if they move from one
town to another as long as they provide
notice it's not clear to me why it would
be why that same and same thing wouldn't
apply to a non-resident person who moved
to New Hampshire why why why shouldn't
it simply be if I live if I have a if I
live in Rhode Island and I have a New
Hampshire permit and I move to New
Hampshire I just have to notify New
Hampshire uh that I've now I've now
moved to New Hampshire and presumably
that the next time my permit comes up
for Renewal I have to get a New
Hampshire permit but to just suspend it
I'm I'm not quite sure why that makes
sense director Mor I'm thinking one
thing is this is a non-resident license
if you're no longer a non-resident then
it seems like the license would be void
uh I think there could be an argument
that it should convert to a resident
license in you know absent to anything
to the
contrary okay okay all right I see your
point Senator GRE but even that would
take a legislative solution and so my
motion still stands that many of these
issues can't be dealt with in this
committee and need to be dealt with you
know on Florida
legislature yeah no I I I think I I I
see the point actually
right any other
questions all right thank you Miss Dean
for bringing these issues to our
attention offer one final thought please
please um when a person applies for a
license to carry in any other state of
every application I've ever seen one of
the questions they always ask that I've
read is have you LIC had a license in
this or any other state revoked denied
rescinded it has a whole bunch of lawyer
words if this happens if this is in
place you're going to have to say yes
and explain
why and the minute you say yes on most
applications it puts you in a category
that you get scrutinized and you're
going to have to say yes the rest of
your life and yes you'll be able to
point to the statute and say you moved
but I can tell you that Massachusetts
and other places when you move as long
as you notify them within 30 days
certified mail your license remains
valid for the end of the term even when
you move out of Massachusetts so long as
you notify them so this is again going
to cause all sorts of problems that I
don't think just to reiterate what you
said is statutory intended or
allowed okay thank you for that date
thank you madam chairman direct if I may
uh again to representative Lynn I I see
where saying automatic suspension um if
you move to New Hampshire could be a
problem because if you have to note to
some other state that you have been
suspended uh I mean r had a license
revoked then that could create
problems so perhaps a legislative
solution really is right no I I agree I
think I think what you and Senator gray
have said is make make sense it probably
should be a solution a legislative
solution okay any other questions or
comments all right the uh the motion is
to approve the rule with the
recommendation that the department seek
legislative clarification of these
issues those in favor I any opposed all
right thank you all very
much next is 2023
248 is on
um Mobile Service Garage rules and
there's a couple of
unclear one uh the agency uses the word
will and will is not Lang uh rule
language it should be shall and that
makes it clear what the acttion the
action is mandatory and the other issue
with this one is um there's a line in in
the
form on the
certification that is not in the rule
text so both of the these things could
actually be fixed with an oral uh
conditional approval just to change that
will to shall and to add that sentence
in so if the agency is willing to do
that oral conditional approval then that
that's all the comments I
have
okay good morning um attorney Dave Hills
for the Department of Safety with me
today is uh Kathy Diamond uh she's the
assistant supervisor of the registration
bureau
DMV um the department would like to
request uh that the committee approve
these rules on the condition that we do
uh fix those two things that attorney
mun is mentioned so
moved
okay any other questions for the
Department comments concerns all right
then the motion is to approve the rule
with
the uh conditions as
stated those in favor I
opposed thank you very
much item
e uh so item e is 2023 177 from
Department of Health and Human Services
on General payment
information the department did submit an
amended conditional approval that
addressed all of the substantive
comments except for one and that is that
this rule has been expired since August
31st of
2000 um so that is a legislative intent
comment um Regarding why this rule has
been expired and whether or not the
department has been enforcing the rules
while they've been expired um and I also
wanted to just bring to the committee's
attention that late yesterday afternoon
we did received some public testimony
from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association which I've put a copy on
your desk
um but this is in support of the rule
um but we haven't received any testimony
um against the rule at this
time okay thank you uh good morning
Nicole Valena uh from Department of
Health and Human Services administrative
rules unit and I have uh Rob Barry legal
counsel for Medicaid with me uh first
and foremost the department is honestly
just taking full ownership that this
rule has been uh expired for an
egregious amount of time none of us were
here at that time of course uh it was
discovered in some recent years and work
did begin on this Rule and has been
worked on
intermittently uh honestly the rule
hasn't been enforced in the past 23
years the department has just relied
upon sort of the framework of applicable
cfrs rsas and any other administrative
rules so really we're here to correct
this Implement a rule that is very much
needed um
which will you know flush out and give
detail to the requirements necessary in
the
rule that's honestly where we
are representative gr so if the rule
hasn't been used in 23 years yet you say
it's much needed can you explain
that yeah I
don't good morning robberry General
Council of the division of Medicaid um
so as uh Nicole mentioned that we have
been relying on federal Authority State
statutes and other administrative rules
what this does is really fill in some
gaps that those uh statutes and rules
don't cover so this is a general payment
rule the other rules we have in place
are more specific to this so this is
just to really add some belts and
suspenders to those um those rules thank
you that makes sense anyone
else it still strikes me as bizarre that
you could have had had it expired for
generation and not
notice I mean yes we again
we uh acknowledge that and take
ownership and again it was discovered
within the past maybe seven years with
the current leadership in place and they
did Begin work on that um and it's been
worked on intermittently and this rule
was actually a complete over Hall to get
up to date with current
processes um so it's it's been a taxing
situation but we are here to correct
that uh and put again some necessary uh
items in place thank
you I'll move to approve second time to
fix it now Senator gr um there is at
least one unfair note
from and I'm not sure
um was that on the conditional approval
because they did submit an amended
conditional approval that addressed that
unclear um they
did I apologize but yes
yeah I would
uh like to comment that if there are
other expired rules I certainly hope
they are being worked on a little faster
than this one has
been all right any further comments
questions
concerns seeing none the motion is to
approve the
rule those in favor I I
opposed all right thank you very
much thank you thank you all right
Lottery we do have public comment on
that yes this is uh two 2023 206 a
lottery
7100 and um there's an unclear
comment that uh public testimony has
been submitted that expresses concern
that it is subjective um it is unclear
if the agency can provide a couple
examples for what take demonstrable
measures means um it would be good if
that was clarified uh the agency
responded however saying that the rule
does not dictate exact measures um to be
taken because every situation is unique
and the language is intentionally left
vague to allow for flexibility and
compliance I'm not sure if the agency
wants to respond to that one um there's
an unclear comment um so the
commissioner can cancel and vacate or
modify the approval of dispensing
devices but um it does not lay out the
criteria the commission will use to
determine when and which approvals the
cancel or to to cancel or modify and
then there's a couple of unclear that
have to deal with a misspelled citation
and incorrect citation and uh some some
web links that are not working other
than that I have no comments but there
is public testimony on
this
okay good morning my name is Valerie
King I'm the director that oversees the
charitable gaming unit at the New
Hampshire
lottery um I don't know exactly what
you'd like to me to start with if you
had any questions or concerns that I
should address first I'd like to comment
that you there's a very nice report on
public comments which I very much
appreciate thank you any other qu
questions or from the
committee no I think think you're good
unless the public testimony brings them
up
okay Michael
M
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee uh my name is Michael mof
represent Community Bingo in Manchester
New Hampshire and filed a written uh
notice about some parts of the lottery
7100 want to thank Valerie first for all
the hard work she put into this program
but as my written submission points out
one of the um sections in the revised
Lottery 7100 is putting new requirements
on what are called gaming
Consultants the gaming Consultants have
uh evolved over the last decade to help
Charities conduct Bingo and Lucky 7
games Bingo and Lucky 7 uh sound like
two different products but in certain
environments particularly the Bingo
commercial Hall environment they're one
and the same so when a uh charity has
signed up to play a bingo game what the
bingo game does is bring in the foot
traffic to sell the Lucky 7 tickets the
gaming Consultants function as a
resource to the Charities and as we know
the uh volunteers for Charities have
evaporating quickly over the last decade
our objection to uh laot
71033 is is putting specific
requirements on the lucky s uh
consultant that are different than the
requirements on the Bingo consultant
when in fact the games are conducted at
the same time secondarily we feel the um
language in the revised
71303 is U very subjective and going to
be impossible for a consultant to be
able to uh uh comply with uh the words
in 7103 E1 a a demonstrable measure and
that's a very subjective uh term that I
don't know how you'd go into a facility
and say what measures have you taken is
that measure so demonstrable that uh a
lack of demonstrable that it violates
the the law itself could you repeat that
citation uh
7103 yes uh sub paragraph e is that
71301 or 03
71033 03 thank you no wonder
e paragraph e subparagraph one requests
a demonstrable measure to be taken to
mitigate all possible conflicts of
interest uh I don't know how that can be
met
um further down in 7103 E3 there's a
request for to keep a detailed log uh
and there's no further definition in
anywhere of the of the um of 7100 what a
detail log is and you've got to look at
this in the uh relationship of the uh
bingo consultant and the application
that they file with the Lottery
Commission the application is approved
by the Lottery Commission the
application covers both Bingo and Lucky
7 it's the same application the same
piece of paper but what
7103 uh 03 does is create a difference
between a bingo consultant and a Lucky
Seven consultant so the same consultant
on the same evening will have two sets
of rules uh they'll have to have a
demonstrable uh effort to mitigate all
conflicts but the Bingo consultant won't
but they're actually one and the same
person
ah well that would certainly be
difficult to
manage and that's that's where our
objection Lies We agree with rest the
rest of what the lottery presented and
they did a great job but this one seemed
to create a conflict that the um the
conflict arose in in the U some issues
that arose between some Bingo
consultants and the certain Bingo
Consultants actually uh work for the
hall but it's impossible to separate
that relationship and I don't think 71
0303 uh does anything to help that it
adds in more confusion uh if you as the
um and pretty much that's all we have to
say is that we'd like to see the similar
uh similar rules for both sides of the
games because they come at the same time
uh and that will conclude my testimony
okay are questions I think we need to
hear the agency answer to the that
concern thank
you
morning again my name is Valerie King
with New Hampshire lottery um I just
want to let you know that it Bingo and
Lucky 7 are pretty intertwined but they
are separate rules but it's difficult to
do promulgation at the same time um so I
am in the process of doing the bingo so
it'll be Lucky Seven Bingo coming right
in behind it um I've already sent out
the draft Bingo rules for stakeholder
pre ruem comments so we'll take what we
receive from that and we'll begin the um
Bingo Ru making subsequent to
this um as for the demonstrable um
measures we we can add language to give
some examples of that but some that I
can think of off the top of my head
would would be number one making sure
that Charities um are clearly allowed to
have Consultants that are not employees
of the hall would be one measure that
they could take policies um clearly
defining what those uh services are that
are for the employer the hall versus
what they're doing as a consultant which
is uh their independent
license the other thing would of course
be to maintain that log that log that
tells the Charities exactly what
services were provided on their behalf
this is something that um a lot of
different type of Consulting uh
occupations would do they' keep a log of
the services they actually provided so
that if the charity has any questions
they know what services were actually
provided on their
behalf um and then we we did leave it
somewhat vague because there are some
unique situations that um might be
unique to a particular hall or a
particular charity so we didn't want to
confine it too
much okay is and this relationship of
this section is only about a gaming
consultant who is
also involved with the facility if
there's an independent consultant this
does not not apply
correct any other questions yeah Madam
chair yes thank you represent haen
Phillips thank you for taking my
question I just wanted to make sure that
I understood correctly that the new set
of rules that will be coming com uh that
you're currently working on that will be
coming in later I can't remember if it
must be Bingo next is it your intention
that they should reflect or mirror the
the Lucky Seven rules that we're
reviewing now yes exactly there was a
lot of intertwining so I wanted to make
sure I got one through before I did the
other otherwise I might end up with
conflicts if I tried to do them at the
same time thank you thank you other
questions all right thank you very much
we do have another person who wishes to
testify Karen
Kung good morning I'm Karen kiring I'm
the executive director for uach
therapeutic Equestrian Center in
Goffstown New Hampshire and we have been
a charity a charity sorry a charitable
organization who has been benefiting um
through Bingo and Lucky 7 for well over
30 years um so I wanted to share some
insight from the charity lens um first
of all I concur with what um I believe
it was Mike had said in the beginning
that it is going to be hard to separate
the lucky s and the Bingo and it is
important that the the rules for gaming
Consultants um with respect to Hall
managers Etc do overlap and align
otherwise there is going to be a
division of Duty and
responsibility I also want to say that
um I recognize the amount of volume uh
rule changes and updating takes but I
have a copy of the latest Bingo rules
that were submitted for draft review for
comment um so the current language is
different in the currently proposed
revisions that are under review for
Bingo so we will want to make sure we
align those two as a charity that's a
small charity but an impactful charity
in the state of New Hampshire I also
feel that there is Clarity and division
of Duties and understanding of the
perceived conflict of interest in the
contracts that are signed when you do
business with a charitable gaming
consultant and then you have your
contract that clearly defines what the
roles and responsibilities of the hall
and the hall manager are so there is a
division of Duty and there is Clarity in
the contractual Arrangements that are
raised there as an employer um
Consulting hiring standpoint so I feel
it's important to not dismiss the level
of knowledge that a charity brings to
the table in understanding employment
law and conflict of interest and
understanding how they need to measure
and mitigate the two I support that the
language should clarify that there could
be a perceived conflict of interest um I
don't think that the rule itself should
indicate log keeping or demonstrable
what to because there are going to be
differences charity to charity um with
respect to knowledge about Bingo and
what the charity wants to own and their
role and responsibility and that should
be defined contractually it should not
be in the rsas in the
legislation I have
been doing business in the charitable
gaming world for many years and it's
complex and without the support of a
hall manager who happens to also be our
gaming consultant with the number of
years that they have had in the industry
to understand the rule making and the
rule changes I have never once had a
concern that their lens wasn't to
benefit the charity rather than
themselves in fact they have
specifically indicated that they have
declined comment or have moved away from
legislation that would benefit them as
the consultant or the hall manager
versus what the overarching good of the
charity is and I will just close by
reminding everyone that without a
charitable organization none of the
charitable gaming would happen so it's
important to listen to the charity and
what the Charity's needs are and how you
can support the charitable work through
your legislation of charitable
gaming thank
you so so you take exception to your
consultant keeping a log of what he did
for you the consultant already discloses
and clarifies what their rules and
responsibility are in our contract for
engagement and that should be sufficient
without having an overarching or an
additional responsibility or task that
they need to do I'd rather they focused
on doing the task rather than telling me
they've done the task that I know that
they're doing and it will be evident to
me in the outcomes of the reporting and
the way B the way Bingo is being run and
Lucky 7 is being handled if they are not
doing the task they are responsible for
doing thank
you
good yes you have a you're you yes
please
again good
morning I think it's important for the
committee to realize that the the
commercial Hall in a bingo Lucky 7
operation has only one form of Revenue
they take a collection on the foot
traffic they get five to s or $10 per
head that's all they get so the conflict
of interest um sometimes arises in this
bingo commercial lucky S type of a world
because there's not enough room for all
the Charities so you have Charities that
want to get in who can't get in but the
commercial only has one Revenue stream
so it's hard to find a conflict of
interest uh in a financial sense when
they can only collect that money so the
this whole
um new paragraph is kind of based on the
inherent conflict of interest which we
believe does not exist and again the I
think I submitted the lucky uh the um
gaming consult in form with my uh
comments and you'll notice that not only
does it have Bingo lucky s it also has
all the particular duties that the
consultant is going to do and they check
them off bookkeeping this and that it's
so it's a um we feel it's a little over
the
top thank you okay thank
you all right Miss King you have a
further
comment hi just want to clarify that the
application and the con contract just
say the types of Duties they may provide
it doesn't actually de detail what was
provided and a charity should be able to
know what was actually provided on their
behalf I'd also like to point out that
while there is the one stream for the
commercial Hall it's um up to $10 per
player that they can receive as rent
however if that owner is also a
consultant they receive additional
Revenue as a consultant and
if there has been questions of what
services are actually being provided for
that consulting
fee okay thank
you comments
concerns gr I'll move what would be the
appropriate because I do believe that
consultant should confirm what they've
done whether or not the evidence is
there I think it needs to be done so and
that's included in the rules correct the
uh that's the detailed log right so it's
a conditional approval so I'll move
conditional
approval is that the correct motion is
that a would this be a uh full approval
or conditional approval
it's it would be a conditional approval
a conditional would be if I'm it's
currently written that
the um only if they're a consultant and
a game Hall that they that they do the
log I am open to a conditional approval
to make the log required for all
consultant but currently the final
proposal just requires the log for the
um uh Consultants who are also
associated with the hall oh okay then
I'll move to approve regular approval
I'll move to approve thank you thank you
for the
correction okay is there a
second hack any discussion comments
questions those can I well I'm sorry
this is time to discuss so I I guess I
wonder if we could ask the could we ask
the person that from the Lottery
Commission to come up one more time Miss
King you know I'm sorry I I have to
confess at the outset that I am I really
am pretty ignorant about the way all of
this stuff works but I'm I just want to
as I read the the rule am I
understanding that someone can be the
owner of a hall where the charitable
gaming takes place that's correct right
and so I just want to make sure I'm
understand how this operates if the
you you mentioned that the owner will
get a stream of Revenue of uh of rent
what do you call rent from from people
who come in to gamble right correct all
right and then what and then that's the
only source of Revenue that the owner
gets as the owner if it's he's also a
consultant he can receive a consulting
fee which has no guidelines on how much
can be charged right but does he get
does does the owner get any take any
percentage of what is gambled no so all
of that money goes to the charity or
what part goes to the charity and what
part goes to who El who who gets the
rest of
it so from the charity would receive
their revenue from Bingo from that the
rent would be taken out the Consulting
fees would be taken out any
reimbursements they have for their
member volunteers would be taken out
there's also a a certain um and not with
Lucky 7 but it with Bingo there would be
um a certain tax on certain types of
games not in Lucky 7 but um and then
what remains is for the
charity okay so in other words is other
than the expenses that are red that are
taken out of the proceeds of the
gambling there's all of all of the net
after those expenses are taken out goes
to the charity there's not some cut that
goes to the owner no okay okay all right
all right thank thank you for CLA thank
you for clarifying
that if I could just follow with the
comment on that um I know from my time
serving on ways and means in the house
that um the interest there's an
interesting breakdown like a wheel that
the Lottery Commission provides us to
show us that breakdown exactly that
you're talking about the the charitable
um distribution um it's it ends up to be
something like 133% I think the
Charities take home something like that
it depends upon what game you're looking
at um the wheel was probably more
associated with um games of chance and
historical question I think that is
correct um thank you for reminding me
yes and I'd like to mention there are
great many small Charities that don't
have the people that
can deal with this and having a
consultant might be very
worthwhile so any further comments
representative uh Schmidt
thank you madam chair so it seems very
clear from the discussion that that when
you have that a lot of this
is not so much written down as when you
have people who are very knowledgeable
very expert very
experienced as in life so often it works
a lot better because it's not all
written down it is learned and skilled
play ERS and the skilled not literally
the players but uh players in the
colloquial sense uh they they make it
work much better than having it all
written
down because then it's kind of like it
all works unless it's a Tuesday right
thank you representative sh any other
comments
okay yes
ma'am
while I understand the heart and the
intention I think it's important to note
that the gaming consultant
license there's nothing in the gaming
consultant license that proves any true
history or competency for being able to
run the
game so by just having a licensed gaming
consultant it does not necessarily give
a charitable
organization any benefit on their
knowledge of the Bingo rules and the
lucky s rules and laws and how a game
should be effectively run to support the
charity and stay in compliance
with we have been fortunate that because
our hall
manager as well not owner but hall
manager as well as also a gaming
consultant to provide us the best depth
and coverage to make sure the charity is
protected
again I think it's important to note
that there needs to still be
responsibility on behalf of each of the
Charities to understand as we would with
any of our business understand who we're
doing business with is it effective is
it cost efficient is it legally and
morally and ethically correct there is
responsibility for the charity to do
that and I feel like it's an overreach
for the Lottery Commission to expect
that we don't know and that we're we're
uninformed and we can't manage that
piece of our business so again I stand
in clarifying that there is a perceived
conflict of interest that should be
mitigated take out demonstrable and then
it's the responsibility of the charity
to do
that thank you for your for your
testimony anyone any other comments
questions so the only the only I mean I
was going to say I I'm I mean I'm I am
going to support the motion the motion
that's been made the only thing I would
say is I do think Mr mlin has a has a
point that the language of demon take
demonstrable steps that is you know it
seems to me it is a little bit
wishy-washy but nonetheless I think the
point is is a good one and you know I I
I I hadn't heard nobody said Mr mcclin
didn't say nobody else said that that
that for example Mr mlin came to you and
said instead of using this language here
would be some more specific language
that we think is good I didn't hear that
um and so in the absence of that I you
know I I think this is is good enough so
to speak so I'm prepar to support it
okay
than thank you we appreciate your
efforts and anyone else all right the
motion is to approve the
rule those in favor I I opposed
okay excuse me for about two minutes
we're going to take a short
recess
right thank you for your
Indulgence we the uh Department of
Justice
um so this is
2023 uh
239 and I have a couple notes to the
committee on this one I wasn't sure if
the committee wanted to hear each of
them or if you just wanted to deal with
the one substantive comment let's start
with that okay so the only substantive
comment I have um after the agency
submitted a conditional approval request
was uh edit unclear on page four of the
conditional approval request
text uh the agency had put a requirement
in the rule text for a dissolution
provision but they put it in the wrong
section on the wrong form it should have
been on form NC
nhc1 which is Justice
402.4903
CA C1 a so the conditional approval
request can be orally amended to just
change that to the correct section and
then after that I didn't have any
substantive comments I just had um some
informational comments for the committee
um all right thank
you you're from the Department of
Justice yes uh good morning Madam chair
and honorable committee members my name
is Michael Haley I serve as the acting
director of charitable trusts at the
Department of Justice um as attorney
card had mentioned um Our intention was
to adopt all of the comments that um she
had made on our final proposal I just
made the change to the wrong section on
one of them so we would request to amend
that conditional approval to make the
change in the correct location all right
that's very good to know any comments
questions is there a
motion did we want to hear the
informational changes as well or
informational notes are we okay with
that otherwise uh it's it's a to you are
if you wish to hear them I read it it
seems fine so I just wanted to yeah I'm
glancing at one of them it says that the
you need to update the date well that's
that will
happen all right representative Len no I
I I just made the motion to to approve
it all right that's the conditional
approval with the uh staff comments and
the
additional reference
correction okay Mary you seconded
okay any comments
questions okay seeing none those in
favor I
opposed thank you very
much is there anyone here from oh yes
there is someone from agriculture
excellent okay this is uh 2022 or 2023
243 on acquisition of agricultural land
development rights and there's one com
comment and it's an unclear wording
comment because the rule requires the
owner of the site to submit a request
for approval for construction or
alteration to the commissioner but the
next paragraph states that it is it it
is the committee who will hold the
public hearing and make the decision on
the approval so it's
unclear why the request is submitted to
the commissioner and if the commissioner
remains involved in the decision making
and it really is a matter of the the
person is already submitting this to the
commissioner and to the municipality so
why would they not also submit it to the
committee um it's it's just an unclear
written uh like paragraph so that's my
only comment on this all right thank
you good morning um committee Patricia
Benner for the Department of Agriculture
markets and food um and I can clarify
that by saying that um in the definition
the commissioner is the chairperson for
the committee so what the rule is saying
is that the commissioner receives the
request and then but the public hearing
is held by the committee so that's the
distinction um so with that
clarification um we're okay with the
rest of the comments so that
clarification it's the the request goes
to the commissioner in His function as
chair of the commission if that makes
more sense conclude that that
language clear no that the the
explanation makes the current language
make sense now okay thank you are there
any other questions or comments from the
committee or is there a
motion I'll move to approve second okay
seconded by Senator Ward
any
discussion all right those in favor I
opposed and and thank you for uh
clarifying that I trust we had a waiver
when we postponed it to this
meeting okay thank
you all
right on to Senator production and
distribution of
food right this is 2023
256 and the only issue I have is uh it's
a legislative intent um because the
statute um States exemptions and it does
not include retail food stores in the
Exempted Homestead food
operation but um another statute
excludes the retail stores from
licensing so it's it's like it excludes
it in one place and then doesn't exclude
it in another place
um and so it's a little confusing so it
really this needs a legislative fix is
the
issue all right thank you good morning
Allison radme administrator for the
administrative rules unit at the
Department of Health and Human
Services good morning Colleen Smith
administrator for the food protection
section within the Department of Health
and Human
Services
okay so if you could explain the uh the
concern sure so I think it it was a a
oversight when that legislation was
passed in 2015 that the other reference
to an exempt Homestead wasn't corrected
um there would be an opportunity in this
legislative session because there is a
bill HB 1565 that is amending the
homestead rule or sorry law so we could
possibly make that fix in this
legislative session with an Amendment to
the that bill okay that be good that
would thank
you all
right so may I ask what the bill number
was again
1565 was what I
heard I heard too and that
is presum well we can find it Madam
chairperson yes yeah we had this in in
Carmer just uh couple weeks ago and or
last week I think and they fixed a
section on dealing with bed and
breakfast anyway as far as snacks was
concerned because that was something
that they weren't allowed to give a
snack after lunchtime you
know okay so be careful so
representative grassy is that bill still
in the possession of the committee if
I'm if I remember correctly yes it is
all right in that case I would move to
approve the rule with the recommendation
that the department work with
representative grassy to make the
appropriate legislative fix
is there a
second representative Schmidt is
seconding any further discussion
comments questions representative Lynn
no no no I'm just getting ready to vote
ah okay and that I don't
know in that case the motion is to
approve with the legislative fix those
in favor I
opposed all right thank you very
much and good luck to
representative the Board of
Education okay this is an interim rule
uh
224-1 uh for visual arts teachers and um
there has been a conditional approval
filed the only issue that remains with
the rules is that they just expired on
January 17th and so the agency filed an
in rule to minimize the time period in
which the rules um were expired and um
that's the only common I have on this
proposal okay this is this
[Music]
number good morning good morning Madam
chair and Committee Member Steve Appleby
director Department of
Education and Julie Shay um
administrative rules coordinator for the
Department of
Education
okay so other than
uh than a couple of weeks of uh
expired rules I I don't believe you've
uh issued any certificates in those two
weeks no okay we have not issued new
licenses okay thank you any other
questions
concerns is there a
motion so moved second okay
discussion those in favor
I all right any opposed than thank you
very much thank
you all right and back to
safety yes so this is um the objection
response for 2023 72 which is the
watercraft safety rules um after
reviewing the objection response I did
still have a number of substantive
comments I had a very long discussion
with the Department um yesterday or the
day before where we discussed how some
of the may be resolved but there still
are some outstanding issues some that
might need a legislative fix um the
first is on page three of the objection
response text it's an unclear comment um
this is one of the ones the
department represented that should they
ask for a revised objection response
that they would just delete this
language from the role text which would
address the comment because they have uh
language in there that is not rule
language uh they had changed the
language from recommendations which is
not rule language to for informational
purposes only which is also not rule
language so just deleting that from the
text would address uh my comment as it's
not something substantive that is needed
for the rule it's not a requirement so
taking it out will not be a problem the
next is on page five it's an unclear
legislative intent comment um the
statute specific ically
exempts people who possess a valid
license issued by the federal government
from complying with the requirements for
a commercial boating
license and
specifically exempts them from passing
an examination administered by the
department in this rule text the
department is adding in a practical
examination in addition to a written
examination the written examination was
in the rules previously and that's what
was Exempted from uh what the exemption
applied to however now we have two tests
that are administered by the department
and it's not clear if the legislative
intent was to exempt these people who
have Federal licenses from both these
exams as the statutes from 2009 this is
a new requirement in the rules um
however in talk with the Department it
seems as though this practical
examination has been something that
they've been doing even though it's not
in the rule text and it may have dated
back to 2009 so if it's a practice
that's been implemented since 2009 once
again there's a issue of legislative
intent of what exactly is being Exempted
so for the purposes of these rules even
though it's it's past bad behavior that
obviously we don't condone it's not
something objectionable at this time in
fact prefer it to be in the rules at
this time it's just whether the statute
needs to be fixed to clarify what is
being Exempted because the
Department's position is that the
Practical exam is not Exempted that is
something these individuals will have to
take even though they don't have to take
the written
exam the next comment's on page eight
it's an unclear legislative intent
comment about not using the statutory
definition for a raft um this is a
technicality
as the manual requires agencies to use
the statutory definition when there is a
statutory
definition in this case the agency does
use the statutory definition in the
first section that has definitions but
this limited section they expand on that
definition it's to put lights on rafts
which they Define as um something more
than what the statutory definition is
the committee could not object if it
feels as though this is an
appropriate policy um even though it is
an objectional basis um but as far as
we're concerned as I said it's more of a
technicality than anything we're
extremely concerned
about there are a number of comments
about uh discrepancies between the rule
text and the forms starting on page 19
um they also go on on to page 21 22 24
25 and 30 I will not get into all of
those at this time unless someone has a
specific question because once again the
agency represented to me should they
request a revised objection um today
that they will go in and they will fix
all those
discrepancies um so uh in the home
stretch here page 30 there's another
unclear legisl legislative intent
comment uh the agency has established a
$20 fee to replace a lost decal for
Moorings and in the statute the statute
lays out fees for renewals um and other
items but it does not say that there is
a fee to replace a lost decal um so it
seems to us that the agency does not
have statutory Authority before this fee
uh it was represented to me that this
fee has been uh in place since the early
2000s and was put into place as part of
an initiative to reduce the fraudulent
practice of obtaining a free decal and
placing it on an illegal
moing however the statute was never
amended to include the fee so once again
it would still be an objectional basis
because there's no statutory Authority
for the fee regardless the reason for
it um and the final comment is an
unclear comment on page
30 um with regard to the decal renewal
forms they had mentioned something about
a special exemp
exception which I had commented that
there was no form submitted for that
particular item however in talking with
the department they clarified that there
it's because there is no re renewal form
for a special exception decal
um because what happens is at the
initial application a person will
request that special exception which
would allow them between two and four
Moorings on their
shorefront and when a person goes to
renew they just use the regular renewal
form and just put the number of Moorings
they wish to renew so at this time that
comment has been clarified and is no
longer
valid I'm glad you got one confirmed all
right Department good
morning good morning uh attorney Dave
hilts again for the Department of Safety
uh with me today I have Captain uh Tim
dun Levy of the uh Marine Patrol
Division um so what I'd like to do is
I'd like to address all of these you
know at a higher level and I have the
captain here if we need to delve into
the you know background the facts of any
particular uh one of these topics um as
attorney Ricard uh stated our ultimate
goal here today is to ask um for a
revised objective from the committee um
you know we'd like to we're going to
address all of these comments um but um
we think that a revised objection would
give us the vehicle to address the
things that can can be addressed without
a legislative clarification which we do
believe needs to happen on two of these
um just going down the list um we do
agree on the page three comment to um
safe C
40203 regarding personal flotation
devices to Simply remove the blurbs that
are really not rules that are just for
informational purposes only so we'll
delete those in a response to a revised
objection um on the I'm just going to
skip skip one uh if we could go to the
page eight comment on the use of the
word
raft this is
safy
40217 so the issue with this is that the
statutory definition of raft means
multiple boats attached together and the
point of this particular section
40217 is what types of lighting is safe
um for the um you know voting uh public
and and everybody else if you have
something that you've attached to to
your boat that floats so it doesn't have
to be another boat it could be something
else that you've attached to the boat
that also floats that sort of expands
the you know footprint of your boat and
you really need to have some lights on
that extra stuff um so that's that's why
we have the different definition in here
and that it's restricted by its own
terms to that section only um if that's
acceptable to the committee we'd like to
keep that one that way so this is sort
of like a trailer behind your boat
that's exactly
I good morning thank you um there's a
lot of history to the de to to the the
common applicable term of raft in the
old days it could have been a log raft
uh with the practice we see now on Squam
Lake is when everybody brings their swim
floats down into the river for the
winter and they're towed multiple swim
floats are being towed behind a boat for
storage in the open water during the
wintertime if they were Towing those
rafts they would need a light if it was
after dark the current definition in
statute however was created
when the legislature wanted to address
the activity of rafting on sandbars
where people would tie their boats
together and drop anchor the legislature
came up with a definition called a raft
so it's really apples and oranges using
the same
term we've had that happen before
yes questions okay thank you that seems
clear enough and that is specifically to
this section which makes sense all right
please continue all right thank you
thank you um I'm going to tackle the one
on page two now um I'm sorry not page
two the page five about the Practical
exam um
so I talked to the captain a lot about
this um it sort of has a lot of history
to it and I did learn a couple more
things I think since I spoke to attorney
Ricard and so I'll share that with the
committee so you know this statute and
it's um
27022 uh was first enacted in 1990 and
it was also amended in 2009 so 2009 is
like a touch Point uh but it really goes
back to 1990 and in speaking with the
captain um he's been employed with the
division of uh Marine Patrol pretty much
that entire time and um what his memory
is is that as far back as that
legislation's been around when it says
you can't operate a a commercial vessel
without having taken an
examination um that since the beginning
they've implemented that with both a
written and a practical exam and you
know the reason is you know the written
test okay yes you need to demonstrate
that you know these things but on top of
that the Practical part is that you have
to demonstrate that you can actually
operate the boat that you want to you
know be a commercial operator of and
it's that additional level of of Public
Safety that the Practical exam affords
um so when um I wasn't involved when the
uh when this rule set went in um but we
put in the blurb in 40207 e uh
referencing the Practical exam so it was
new to the rules but not new to Marine
Patrol and neither was the written exam
and you know the way that we've got it
here in our objection response you know
would specify that the part of the
statute that exempts a person from the
statute's requirements would exempt them
from the written exam but not the
Practical and again that goes back to
the degree of Public Safety that we
think is required so you you show us a
federal license okay you obviously know
enough where you know we don't have to
be concerned about you taking the
Practical exam but can you still drive
that boat um and um so that's why from a
policy um angle we we think it's
important
um I the way that it it's been written
mentions both the written knowledge exam
and the Practical exam and since I spoke
to attorney Ricard I actually couldn't
find a reference to the written exam in
the rules maybe it's in there maybe I
missed it but um so I just wanted to
clarify that because that may not be
accurate that the written exam was
mentioned in the rules before too so um
I think this is an opportunity for some
legislative clarification if the
committee agrees with the Department on
the policy so that you know the statute
can specify that the examination that's
required has a written component has a
practical component and if you agree
that the exemption should cover one but
not the other then that can be in the
statute and it would put everybody on
clear notice
um the uh the next I'm sorry any
comments yeah I mean I I I I don't
disagree at all with what you say and my
only concern though
is until there's a legislative change I
guess I have some question about the
authority to I guess I have some
question about the
authority to to make this distinction in
the in the
regulations that's um did you yes did
particularly since the uh people with
Federal licenses are explicitly Exempted
from the exam and and it doesn't specify
which exam is
involved thank you that's a good
question and and I think what
procedurally we've always considered the
Practical exam an extension of the
written or an extension of the process
to get your credential because it only
applies to certain boats um of s
significant size uh we are not concerned
about the person who's getting their
commercial license to tow at a kids camp
on on tubes um what we are concerned
about is someone that applies for a
commercial license in New Hampshire to
drive the Mount Washington the Practical
exam applies to the Mount Washington
when someone comes to us with a federal
credential perhaps it's a 100 ton
captain's license or maybe it's just a
six-pack license from the Sea Coast
where they're they're a fishing
charter um and they come to us with with
book knowledge which we are readily
accepting however they're looking to
make that jump and drive the Mount
Washington
conversely um you might have someone
that's very capable of operating a a
have a commercial pilot's license drives
a operates a
747 and now they want to do a uh um
drive or a pilot a Cessna and just do c
plane tours while that's not in the
Boating realm it's an example of
somebody with tremendous capability
but can they go from from a large
aircraft to a small Cessna that operates
completely different and all we're
concerned about is making sure that the
vessel they're operating of of of a
certain size they're capable of of
operating uh in a practical sense rather
than the book
sense thank you totally agree yeah no I
I mean I I I'm not I I completely
understand what you're saying and I
agree with you completely I that I don't
think it still does doesn't really
answer the question that it you know the
to do that in this regulation does seem
inconsistent with the statute and so I I
you know I mean it would it really would
be I think adding on to the statute
which I don't I don't think the rules
are supposed to do
so you know what that says to us is we
need to change we ought to change the
statute and we ought to try to do that
you know as soon as possible so if I
could respond I I'd like to try to take
another stab directly answering your
question and um you know it's not a
perfect solution I do think that the
perfect solution would be to
legislatively clarify this area as I've
discussed but um one of the facts here
is that um the department has rulemaking
Authority in RSA 270 colon 11 uh and at
Roman 1C uh gives the commissioner the
authority to adopt rules relative to the
classification examination and
certification of captains Masters
engineers and Pilots which are all the
categories of who can operate
commercially um operated or used on any
public Waters of the state so that Ru
making Authority is sitting there and
it's on this subject so you know is it
the cleanest thing no it's not the
cleanest thing but we do have statutory
Authority in this rulemaking to rule
make on this topic so you know we could
say that you know that the that that's
the authority that we're exercising to
cover this you know what we feel is an
important Public Safety uh practice
until the legislative clarification is
made well thank you for that information
but I don't think the commissioner's
broad rulemaking Authority should be
used to overwrite a specific statutory
exemption which is what people with a
federal license
have and no I that's that's my take too
I think it's uh it's un you know I mean
you've got this specifically says this
statute a person uh a person who has a
federal license shall be deemed so
that's um I think that's hard to get
around that
exactly right comments director moral uh
one way to address that if the committee
uh as a whole believes that they
shouldn't have this right now uh but
there is the agency wants to do a re
rised objection to clean up other things
you could Grant the revised objection
and then with this issue remaining in
the uh revised objection response you
could if you wish enter a final
objection they would still be able to
adopt the rule but uh it would be over
the committee's objection and if anyone
challenged then uh the burden of proof
would lay with the
Department well we certainly want to
Grant the Revis objections yes I think
that that is the way to go
because we'd love to get all the other
details fixed but this one line
specifically needs a legislative
clarification that the exemption
includes the entire gamut of testing or
that it doesn't include the entire gam
of testing whichever the way the
legislation goes so I'll move to had to
Revis the objection request okay is
there Mo second second
second do we need yeah attorney Hills
yeah I'm sorry to um interrupt um that
just the one thing I wanted to touch on
too that needed a legislative
clarification is that um replacement
decal fee um oh we haven't even touched
on the repl decal let's talk about that
I was happy to get the uh the revised
objection but I yeah we haven't got it
yet so please continue about this Revis
can I just can I just before I forget
about can I just raise one issue I'm not
sure whether how this would work out I
certainly have this is the first thing
that came up but in terms of changing
legislation I have a bill that's before
Transportation U that deals with uh
trying to create an exemption for
certain certain commercial uh the need
for a commercial license it's it has
nothing really to do with this but um it
it's not it hasn't cleared
Transportation yet and it might be that
you could um work with uh uh
representative Walsh to do a non-gain
amendment to that bill that would that
would include the changes that we're
talking about here and that might be a
way of getting that done now you know
pretty quickly okay I believe so we will
we'll do it that way representative Lynn
will take the lead with the Department
on getting the clarification on this
testing requirement all right now about
those uh replacement decals okay thank
you very much
um so as attorney Ricard uh teed up for
the committee um what I've been able to
find out about the fee is um as she said
it's been around since the early 2000s
that the captain can speak more to this
but you know in terms of the why it
exists and why we think it's important
that it continue um is um to First deter
the abuse of you know the ease of
getting these decal and then you know
like it was said putting it on illegal
Moorings I don't like that at
all the the other piece is excuse me
representative Schmidt you don't want
what well we don't want this abuse that
they're getting the the decal and then
they're applying it on a right that's so
the so the question is oh I've got other
questions but please continue thank you
um the the other piece is not just a
pure deterrence but um the the amount of
the fee covers the cost of Marine Patrol
Personnel to physically go out on a boat
and confirm that the issued replacement
decal is put on a legal Mooring um so
there's actually two parts to why we
think that um you know it's important to
continue to have that I think by this
time it's clear that there's no existing
uh statutory Authority for the fee um
and there should be um so you know we
would would love to um you know partner
with member of Jil car for sponsorship
or go out and seek another sponsor to
get that legislative clarification to
continue what we think is an important
practice I have a question how many
replacement decals are issued over the
course of a year is that a large
percentage of the total um it it varies
from year to year um I would say that
this past year we had something like 150
of about 55 500 that we issue every year
prior to the replacement fee being added
in the rules uh we were seeing hundreds
uh every year and and It ultimately
would be a neighbor complaining that hey
this morning's popped up in front of my
neighbor's
Frontage
anyway for whatever reason we would go
down and find that that Not only was the
replacement decal being displayed on a
morning the original decal was being
displayed on a second morning
and so uh when when you look at the the
value in being able to have your boat on
the water often times it becomes a
revenue stream for a person with
shorefront property to be able to
provide Moorings to people and so uh the
legislative uh uh language in the
statute says they are not for rent this
is not to be a money-making uh
Enterprise in in in providing Mings to
people so uh there is value in those DEC
and so it it requires us to go out and
make sure that we're truly seeing the
replacement decal uh being used uh in
the spirit of a
replacement thank you that's uh
enlightening all right any other
questions C can I just raise a question
about this is one that has not been
referenced earlier but I saw on page one
of the proposed change in the in saf C4
01.03 the commercial vessel
definition and I I guess this is sort of
along the lines of of a comment that was
made earlier by the staff regarding
something later but where the last
sentence of that says this term includes
any vessel carrying passengers for
hire as a common carrier of passengers
or property that seems to me to
be really confused so if I have a vessel
that
carries that commonly carries property
only is that covered by this or
not ultimately sir it would depend on
the length of the vessel being used
we're not concerned about the gentleman
who is for higher higher hauling plywood
out to an island for someone on a
pontoon booat but if you've got a 60ft
barge with an excavator hauling sand for
a septic system then then it would
apply if I understood question so that a
small boat that carries passengers for H
would qualify as commercial but carrying
Freight in on a small boat would not
apply it would still meet the definition
of commercial and they would need to
have a commercial license but they would
not have to have the Practical exam ah
thank you but okay thank
you um and and just on that point as
well uh the statute statutory definition
also kind of includes it anyway um it
says a commercial vessel means any
vessel used as a common carrier of
passengers or property operating on a
reg regular schedule so this just
clarifies that that also applies for
those boats that Do it For Hire not just
as part of their own business but also
for hire so it's also kind of
implemented in the statute itself so
that includes water taxes as well as
regular rotes correct yes okay other
questions all
right so
um director we do have a uh motion on
the table Schmidt and hilts oh I'm sorry
Lynn uh moved to do a revised
objection request a revised objection
yes and I could we add to that that the
department work with
um representative
ly to to get legislative clarification
on the testing
requirements and this bill with don't we
also need something on the fee I was
just about to get to that sorry sorry
is there someone who would be interested
in taking on the issue of the authorized
fee no representative gr I think you're
overloaded I am happy to give it a try
okay thank you that that would require
an
amendment preferably somewhere on
something in ways and means but U work
work with the uh the committee and and
come up with something
is it it sounds like it's a very
reasonable fee and in fact that $25 may
not be
enough so Madam chair just to clarify
the motion is is to
um revise the objection under the two
conditions that the department work with
representative Lynn and representative
hackin Phillips on their yes needed
changes it's basically that we ask for
revised objection response to
incorporate staff comments which they've
agreed to and the two legislative
comments as well thank you okay everyone
agree all right so we have a motion any
further
discussion all right those in favor I
opposed okay thank you very much and
good luck you know can I just not just
so you your information the bill I'm
talking about the bill I'm talking about
is HB 1158 that's the one that's before
Transportation now okay thank you ah
thank you that will help make it easier
for the uh for the team to get the
proper amendments all right w
why all right is there any other
business that we need to
consider on the agenda we had listed uh
de's uh alteration of terrain rules
which did go into effect last year but
it's my understanding that the home
builders asso ation is still talking
with the Department about the issues
that he had concerns about yes I I heard
that also other than that it would just
be if the committee wish to
uh vote to not hold its uh public
hearing I mean it's continued meeting
meeting sorry if anyone objects the
continued meeting speak now otherwise
we'll cancel
it okay and I believe we are adjourned
thank you
all